foreign
Americans
were wrongly told they were approved for
student loan forgiveness
CBS news reporting about 9 million
Americans with student loans who had
applied for Biden Administration student
debt relief program mistakenly received
emails last month that said their
applications have been approved
the messages were part of updates the
Department of Education issued in
November to inform 16 million debt
relief applicants they've been approved
to have up to twenty thousand dollars
forgiven but an additional 9 million
people received emails saying they
received loan forgiveness when they had
not been approved for Relief because the
process was halted due to Legal
challenges and others who hadn't yet
applied for the student loan relief
program also received the email the
error was made by the federal Services a
contractor for the education department
which sent the emails the mistake may
only compound confusion among some
borrowers about the debt relief program
which for now remains in limbo due to
several legal challenges with the
Supreme Court earlier this month
agreeing to hear one of the cases in
February
oh
I saw this yesterday and this just
annoys me
come on there's enough confusion around
this already nine million people getting
an email saying they've been approved
why were there even emails sent out in
the first place saying they've been
approved when this hasn't passed
this program hasn't passed it's not in
action why were 16 million people quote
unquote approved when they haven't
actually been approved the program
hasn't been approved
well Biden had approved it and he had
issued the um the announcement but none
of the systems were in place to cause
the approvals to actually happen and
knowing that there were legal challenges
uh to his
program which may yet need a
congressional approval we don't know
we'll see
lots of stuff up in the air but given
all of that this is just again it's a
political play they accidentally told
50 percent more people that they had
approval than did accidentally
so at a minimum we have a
level of incompetence that is
only tolerated at the federal government
level
um I mean this level of incompetence I
mean for MC Solutions send out an email
to and and
to to
50 more people than we were supposed to
telling them we were going to give them
money I mean
can you imagine can you imagine yeah I
mean that level of incompetence in the
business world how we would have reacted
to uh the people internally that did
that right it would be a train wreck
yeah and instead they went oh oops well
and I think that's what's so crazy is
you know the 16 million people who got
the email that was you know supposedly
correct and then they're sending out
these refund checks how do they know the
difference about what's going on well
you don't you don't you can't tell
because you don't know if you're got one
of the real emails or one of the ones
that was wrong but even if they got the
real email and then they got the results
there's still no forgiveness because
it's not been gotten through the court
system right so even if like the
semantics of the timeline of like this
16 million were before the court order
and then this nine Millions after right
now the reality is the program hasn't
passed
like right now it is still in limbo
there is no guarantee right now that
student loan forgiveness is going to
happen it might none but there's not a
guarantee no guarantee none whatsoever
and um but I mean this is at a minimum a
gross level of incompetence or if you
want to be more cynical you could go
well they did this on purpose what do
you think Dave did they do this on
purpose
it's too large
to be an oopsie
I mean if you said okay 16 million and
we sent out
1 million
as an oops okay but nine million nine
you know the effort it takes to get nine
million emails out
that's not a you know one little guy
with two keystrokes
that's not how that works so I mean uh I
feel like okay so Dave people have been
asking me do you think that there is any
chance this program is going to be
approved and I know a lot of people have
strong opinions that they feel like
there's no way that it's going to be
approved but I kind of feel like we have
a government that is so obsessed with
debt that they've literally led us
trillions of dollars into debt they've
made Moves like this I mean I could see
it going both ways
in the sense of like they're not afraid
to put us more in debt
there's
you know there's so many things have
happened uh
in all areas of our society in the last
10 years that I thought would never
happen in my life so what do I know I
uh I certainly wish it was not going to
be approved but I don't uh and I don't
think it's gonna be anytime soon and I
know for sure
that if you've got 25 000 in student
loan debt and ten thousand of it goes
away with this that I'm 100 sure you
will not hate yourself for just going
and paying off your debt because it is
your death there's that key part of it
too so you clean up your life and you
don't wait on the government to fix your
life I can't really figure out what the
flip they're going to do it's the Island
of Misfit Toys you don't know where
they're going to come from next I you
know what they're playing politics with
it for sure
uh but it's under there somewhere
there's also the belief that they should
actually do this
um at some point and so I don't know how
long they got to wear out the court
system or they got to run it through
Congress what has to happen but oh my
gosh I feel like for me I'm you know if
it gets approved and people get their
loans forgiven like I will cheer for the
people who are out of debt I will cheer
for the people who had their debt
reduced what scares me though is what is
happening with kind of the trickery and
confusing people and that's where I'm
like go ahead and pay off your loans now
because that is the thing you can do to
control the situation this is so up in
the air I think this is really confusing
a whole generation on what the
responsibility is with debt and what
they need to do to to get control of
their finances so ah man it just breaks
my heart what's happening because I've
just I've seen the pain in people's
voices when they're like man I thought I
was debt free I was counting on this
twenty thousand dollars in student loan
forgiveness I'm a Pell Grant recipient
and then they're like wait wait what am
I debt-free or am I not and that's just
sad you can get debt free regardless the
this is what happens when you wait on
the government to fix your life